[Music]
we are about to right now 5 4 3 2 1 hey
everyone what's up what's up welcome to
simulation we are featuring Valentin
preobrazhensky hello thanks for coming
on to the show this is gonna be a blast
I'm super excited to talk about
decentralization about blockchain about
cryptocurrency about law token we've
been doing this a year and a half now
the brand comes something like one year
ago but I'm doing this capital markets
in something like a decade yes and in
different forms I working at hedge funds
when did equities portfolios created
back office to facilitate settlement of
trades and when I found blockchain which
automates a lot of settlement a lot of
contracts a lot of middlemen and
bureaucracies did really exciting dudes
can automate a huge amount of
transaction is means something like 150
trillion of dollars daily daily to Noah
which is settled
nearly manually that 12 entities
involved to settle trades it takes cheap
used two days 150 trillion dollars per
day is transacting across the world and
there's 12 centralized entities that
manager majority of that entity's legal
separate organizations needed to settle
one trade or shares transferred to from
bias to Saros that's 1206 included oh do
come any middlemen like to custody
settlement centers with exchanges and so
on it's huge blockchain is done
real-time or to my to
so yeah your your background is lots and
lots of finance hedge fund management
assets also your director at the founder
Institute as well in Moscow yeah for a
little bit we I'm a mentor there we've
had a day on the show twice yeah we love
founder Institute accelerating
entrepreneurship into the world so
important that's huge famiglia
yeah yeah and see you're Russian right
yes privyet oh free viet and that's
great because it seems as though russia
is kind of one of the many important
pieces to the global equation Russia
China the US Europe Africa's coming up
more of Asia's coming up South America
and so these whole pieces need to work
together and you leading the the
decentralization and getting rid of
these 12 middlemen involved with the
transaction and your do you have a
secret sauce for lot Oken and for you
said you started with this community
this idea of community yes so what I
work at hedge funds I love to predict
future of companies their cash flows
technologies and invest I love this but
I also wanted to create something which
put people together create products and
so on that's why I went to founder
Institute to kind of get experience and
my 250 meetups to find ideas and
teammates for global technological
business and that's how I found
blockchain is this meetups yeah and in
order to get this real great ideas and
teammates I should find a way to bring
the right people and the same spot yeah
and that's what I use it so I'm going to
secret sauce and I use it this for
I ain't going for so so by having these
meetups where people are getting
together that have similar values about
wanting to decentralize or wanting to
maybe have the ability to trade
cryptocurrency for financial assets like
a cryptocurrency is a new economic
substrate for the planet then you kind
of took these 250 groups and you said
okay in the meetup groups
okay now we're hosting a blockchain
economic forum so come in at 10 not 250
meetup groups no different formats it's
something which I gather it's not in
meetup.com it was online offline yeah
and so I invite personally most of the
1000 participants so I select those 4 ah
motivated and have ideas and problem
solving can integrity put them together
create environment which makes very kind
of open and they talk from early morning
to midnight Gary Gensler former CFTC
chair under President Obama
he stated our partner to midnight it is
hotel suit mm-hmm and everybody talked
to him like he's one of kind of one of
this crowd Tim Draper enjoyed very hot
discussion with Gary Gensler
there was a kind of powerful very
powerful battle between two positions
one is that anybody should have
opportunity to learn to make mistakes
and have access to newest in VC asset
classes
it's similar to walking rights right we
want all people to be able to vote
we don't say only you're not qualified
you don't vote right
but now existing security situation says
you're not qualified you can't buy buy
into venture deal right discrimination
right and Tim Draper wants to be
everybody qualified so it's better to
help to educate people rather than keep
them out of 30% return asset class so
rich people have access to a super high
return yes right people who are not so
lucky they're not allowed mm-hmm and
that's the maze yeah yeah yeah that's
really important right there okay so so
very wealthy people have the option to
invest money and it makes it easier for
them to invest money because of things
like the SEC and other Regulation
Commission saying that okay you're
qualified investor you can qualify as to
invest so when you democraty
democratize investing for the middle
class and the low SES class through
things like cryptocurrency through
things like deregulation yeah it can be
both really helpful for beat for them to
make money and and and become investors
but also it can be a little bit we might
have a couple more of these Bernie
Madoff issues as well because of
deregulation so it's important to maybe
find a way to do you know what that
looks like yeah yeah so of course
there's a problem that there will be
mistakes there will be pain with people
made wrong decisions but it brings in
incentives incentives to politician to
make education system more it's written
more widely more financial knowledge
knowledge how economy works how
like how businesses works so just put
pressure on politicians - yeah
educate people so they kind of make
better informed decisions and people
also learn the more mistakes and this is
an experience and today eventual asset
class have an average return of 30% on
average yeah versus six or seven percent
I could just stock index right I did
perform an asset class it's not
accessible for many Americans yeah it's
accessible for people who have networks
who are accredited who have wells see
then you you think that then the this
makes sense that then the push for
middle and low SES socioeconomic status
to be able to make investments through
cryptocurrencies that will put pressure
on to politicians to help educate the
basic citizens about the way that the
financial markets work and how to get
involved because right now a lot of
people are ignorant in the finance of
the financial markets including myself I
know so little I know nothing and on the
other hand America has the largest
involvement of population into stocks
traded so capital markets are kind of
the most development and this is also
because of regulations which ensure that
public stocks information is transparent
and reliable and this kind of allows to
make informed decisions and learn learn
if you understand correctly what's going
on or not and listen to news trying to
kind of analyze and this is very
powerful new creation process so people
start to understand how regulation how
policies in their wealth and
they are better waters yes southern
voting became smarter and this makes
everything more sustainable yes but
still there is an asset class which is
not accessible to public and the reason
why it wasn't accessible because
startups were not eager to share their
secret sauce and they had no the cost of
access to public we are very high i and
venture funds they are focusing on exits
of startups in to Google Facebook and so
on so it's kind of very can close it
like a system hundred miles around this
big companies which kind of destination
point for startups
so now installation point is the Stock
Exchange's no don't stop keep the
exchanges mm-hmm
where startup can skip venture can skip
private equity you can skip merger and
acquisition is a big company and go
directly to capital market this is a new
situation and yes existing security
regulation is not design it for this yes
so it should be updated yes it's
efficient for existing kind of public
stock market but it did blind to this
new technology
yes which provide access from
enterpreneur to so you can go the new
ICO format enables the initial coin a
free format enables an entrepreneur to
give away asset a que tokens to
customers to the public as an initial
coin offering they can purchase tokens
purchase shares of the company that
skips the sec that skips
these Regulation Commission's it skips
traditional venture capital and all of
the craziness and that yeah this is a
potential opportunity now entrepreneurs
they do not normally issue equity tokens
it's rare they issue and found something
like utility talking utility charges
completely confusion actually this is a
currency the issue currency yes yes in
really of their currency is a result of
adoption adoption transactions and say
and kind of deposits on wallets to
facilitate this transaction some of
these deposits is the demand for tokens
and then this is a silly token this is
different than equity tokens is traded
between people yes the difference is the
value of this token is driven by similar
mechanics like currency so it's driven
by number of transactions and amount of
tokens of currency needed to facilitate
these transactions so it's not like an
assets I said as it generates a cash
flow due to efforts of others this is
secured hmm but token which is used it
to buy and sell something mm-hmm this is
currency this unit of exchange so there
there is a confusion and there are many
voices in regulators saying that this
tokens shall be regulated as securities
they say 99% of tokens look like
securities there's a name right
intuition that people invest in them
this expectation of profit however the
profit is driven not by an asset is
driven by transactions right
this is the price appreciation of
currency is driven by number of
transactions mm-hmm it's not not by an
Isis to generate profit mm-hmm very
different things and things should be
regulated like currency and those tokens
which should be regulated differently
potentially but but more like cards
smaller currencies the tokens which do
not have any link no asset just mean of
exchange or value of this currency yeah
should be made more like currency
security tokens which have was linked to
your asset to cash equity of the company
equity just this more like this is
secure and however this security shall
be available to you everyone
yeah there should be some information
discover yes this should be regulated
there shall be some requirements not to
provide misleading information all right
but this is there could be Marcus
include regulation obliged right so the
people kind of see statements which are
not misleading you don't even need
security sir come on current situation
for this you can use marketing standards
and what shall be different from
security is that you do not need
qualification you do not need lockup
period I believe so it is this deserves
discussion it may be kind of definitely
it may be a bit more complex right there
could be a different person course but
the fact is that 30% return asset bus is
not available was not available for
public now there is a technology which
makes it total sense to sell early-stage
companies
two broad range of investors yeah and
why don't you allow everyone to have
equal opportunity yeah why not allow
everyone to have equal opportunity so
this is a reoccurring thing that we talk
about on the show a lot is giving kids
across the world children across the
world equal opportunity to maximize
their potential and there needs to be
some sort of basic minimum for that it
needs to have security for your water
your food your shelter your education
your health care these basic things that
enable you then to be creative to start
businesses to want to achieve things
with your life so I think that when you
are initially talking to me about the
reason why you started law token and
these blockchain Economic Forum's that I
really felt really drawn to your mission
tell it teach us about your mission why
you're having these blockchain economic
forms well you just said giving people
equal opportunity blockchain changes
fundamentals of power to realization so
our fundamentals is everything is built
on rules and contracts this rules design
is incentives to us so we do something
which create value rather than kind of
take value of others Frances rooms and
contracts is the most important things
and we use bureaucracies and middlemen
to make contracts and rules working so
democracies and medium as they are very
important but now you have thoughts in
which kind of automate many of their
jobs Tim Draper fed at look at our
blockchain occur a forum that 80% of
state functions can be automated with
blockchain I am totally agree with name
elections can be done on watching so you
don't need ballot balls where different
parties come to double-check each other
that water counted properly so
you will be able to walk from a chat
board that's in bonds will be counted
very fastly and anybody actually can
create legitimate port right especially
this is very important for countries
where access to elections is controlled
by a small group yes fair and free
elections yes yes this redesigned the
power game so now it opens the road to
those who create support base by
protecting property rights human rights
they can gather the support base and
compete with those who redistribute
property from less loyal to morale I'll
just create political machines which are
capable to cut access to elections of
those who kind of play fair game right
this is a game changer for developing
countries and each and law cannot unlock
400 trillion dollars per year 400
trillion 100 trillion per year is
currently on you can't tap into it
because of bureaucracy and because of
the middlemen and shift it to be to
political machines okay and incentives
to use technologies that six and more
billion people
productivity's below ten thousand
dollars six billion people the
productivity which is below ten thousand
per year yes the total war GDP
there's the managed term Hatem has going
total GDP global product is 80 trillion
dollars
total global yes it's 80 trillion 80
trillion dollars GDP okay yes there's no
such thing as a trillion dollars what
are you talking about and six billion
produce million 50 trillion and another
billion produce 30 and there are 500
million which productivity sounds like
$70,000 mm-hmm and six billion or more
have productivity ten times lower why
the modern level of technology allows
them to be as productive is this 500
million people but they do not use
technologies why are they stupid as a
short-sighted access not no access yeah
yeah probably it's not a problem it's
access what is it it's problems that if
they use technology they get penalized
penalize yes for example fertility of
land in Mexico
ten times lower than in the US that's a
few miles the reason why is that land is
social the land is rented from
bureaucrats if you invest in
fertilization several years and
productivity grow then they will be a
friend of a politician kissing walls
good land I would take it to me yeah and
the person who invested in
virtualization lose everything and he
may be put into jail just to keep him
quiet
mm-hmm mostly corruption yes yes people
people try and become better off in the
world and then corruption comes and
squeezes their throats other people take
what they tried to fertilise yeah
so if we create something valuable yes
how do you feel that making the playing
field equal is gonna do anything about
corruption if you just make it equal for
everybody then you're gonna we're gonna
just have different people that are
gonna [ __ ] it all up I don't feel that
making an equal playing field is gonna
do anything about our current problem
when people get all that money and get
all that power that we you know we have
this element inside us which you know
this greed I want it all and I don't
want these other people to have what I
have and that's what that's like what is
what are we doing about that yes so
you're saying that if we just do what
other people opportunities they will
behave in similar way right I'm just
saying I'm just playing devil's advocate
here in that that's all I don't I don't
know what the answer is
I'm not saying that these people are
good these are bad we should kind of
change them to each other no I'm talking
about power design checks and balances
right if there is an equal access to
elections different politicians who use
different support base then once there
is a chance for a politician who
coordinates those who benefit from
protected property rights into his
support base and they bring him into
power and then he started to protect
property rights right and he competes
with other politicians in terms of who
protects property rights better who
protect interests of the wider range of
people so and this is possible in case
if there's a political competition and
if there is an access to elections of
different types of politicians
so in traditional political systems
power is maintained by redistribution of
property from less organized to more
loyal and those who get an opportunity
to take claims of us to take profitable
business they are very loyal
because if patron is out of the power
the victims will come back and say
please give big back my land please give
back my business and you go to jail all
right so this way they're very kind of
working hardly to keep his partner in
power yes and this completely destroys
property rights and free markets which
is a major driver for Kalima growth
protected property rights means that if
you invest and get profits you get this
profit pre-market means that if you do
great product if you invest in your team
in technology then you're kind of have a
better chances to maintain market share
I decide create incentive to use modern
technology without disincentives there's
an incentive to kind of take give rights
to yes I support and say this as is
proper to yep do not so the general idea
is that the low SES and the middle SES
when given equal access to opportunity
through technologies like these
decentralization technologies blockchain
cryptocurrencies on blockchain
but elections on books yeah like
elections on blog change exam also also
access to to things like enabling that
to be a part of equity exchanging with
with tokens rather than currencies and
equity like fiat currencies now with
cryptocurrencies that's this is what it
does is it it's it brings them into the
conversation when low and middle SES get
to be a part of the conversation
it it feels like there will be less
corruption that's what the feeling is we
don't know what the exact outcome will
be but generally the more people that
come in and are able to participate in
the elections and in the way the
government is structured and the way
that entrepreneurship and business is
structured and economies are structured
the more you'll have a a general more
less corruption that's that we hope we
hope this state and political system is
more remote garage this capital market
think it's less about Corrections more
about price discovery liquidity and
access of investors to opportunity to
invest and wider range of asset classes
and also opportunity for entrepreneurs
or isothermal's to get connected to
investors and get investment faster so
it makes a flow of money smarter flow of
resources into enterprises into assets
which create better well bigger value in
this case jobs which are more productive
so people move to more productive jobs
in the lifetime productivity is bigger
than net present value of their life
became greater yeah and there's there's
another aspect to this which is that
taking and democratizing access control
to information right now is information
asymmetry it's not symmetrical venture
capitalists have more access to
information to government to equity then
it's asymmetrical low SES doesn't have
that same connection to that information
so by bringing them into the
conversation the more information
symmetry that you have typically the
more you'll see if potentially a
flourishing I can imagine that
there can be kids maybe who didn't have
access to
I believe universities but they just
learn you YouTube video founders they
radian analyze their business and they
can do smart decisions so this kind of
they cannot do a career in venture
capital because they do not have a
degree education they talk different
language but in case if or venture stage
companies start to do the equity stock
and sale online they have access to it
and they can kind of show their best and
perhaps we can see there are some kids
which are kind of genius mm-hmm without
nothing on the street which is also fine
with make them smart converse yeah
without the ideally there is intelligent
people in all around in the most
unsuspected places yes and you know
let's give them a chance as well but
that was this future the best of luck I
don't see a gradual shift I think
something big has got to happen where
this is just the this is just a new way
in gosh we're gonna trust
whoever has builds the best AI machine
is is who's gonna have control in the
future whether it be the United States
Russia or China or maybe a you know an
underdog somewhere a wild card but it's
something be it's not gonna be a gradual
change to this you know wonderful new
world where everyone has a chance did
you see what Sofia said
at our book Shane occurred on the quorum
feed the robot yes I know Sofia we're
trying to get around the show she said
pretty smart things that are kind of
[Music]
human fertility declined
probably because chips productions
increased and information about how to
organize atoms into infrastructure for
life shifted from DNA and brains into
computers alright so if life is a
program which use energy to create
storage for itself by putting atoms into
our bodies and this all of this in this
camera and screen of this it's all
information in a structure right behind
it you owe the mission all of this is
organized atoms which help information
to be stored and replicated and this
information is now shifting into chips
computer chips and perhaps artificial
intelligence can process this more
efficient but this would be some
evolution and natural selection between
artificial intelligence before it gets
its own purpose of life it's all up to
who's been a program the machine really
the adjust machine programmed by men
with a passion and vision compassion
envision something good Donald Fagen
song igy International Geophysical Year
speaks about the machines Valentin
you're right though that we're moving on
from the biological restrictions and
however the neurons also write is that
the way that we make the transition pass
the biological so
to where information is then processed
via chips as well as communicated
digitally and preserved digitally the
transition to that is potentially going
to be messy it's probably not going to
be a bunch of flowers
if blockchain and cryptocurrency are
able to to really make the next couple
of decades less violent and and more
harmonious more transparent then maybe
it won't be that messy but whoever is
programming the world leading artificial
general intelligence that's going to be
the ones that get most of the save
they're going to be the ones with the
guns we're already seeing that yeah I
hope there's a secret room somewhere
where men and women of all different
cultures and all different backgrounds
that just have that one thing in common
that are they are qualified to speak on
behalf of whoever they represent to make
that decision and what's happening in
the current political structure is is
just smoke and mirrors it's
entertainment to distract us as they try
to build this and that's the best of
everybody that's living on this planet
we can't deny you know the the history
of these key cultures and I don't think
anybody has left do did we get to kill
one culture is there like a cutter than
the Neanderthal I mean we're all still
here right we weren't we didn't get a
chance to you know do genocide never
really actually succeeded everybody's
still here no and I'm not I don't know
I'm not uh but it's well done genocide
succeeded several times but so what do
you mean by success like killing a
million or more people is pretty
successful are there none of them left
no there are usually at least some left
yeah so it didn't succeed everybody the
artificial intelligence genocide is much
more likely to succeed
by second so their reason why but if
this violence happens is because their
groups which benefit on stays in
property another group and so they have
attentive to claim that inferior they
don't have right this fight can be
killed yes and they either take their
territory or progress your wealth or
bank accounts of gold so there is an
incentive there also there are also
competition for resources yeah so so
this we should be in somehow in
competition which they are to have this
problem but I think we have slightly
different source of energy and different
in our resource base yes
today a I benefits a lot on humans
without us I kind of do not evolve yeah
so I should be interested in us so I
think that competition between AI can
happen so they should be in conflict
with each other before we create natural
selection which in a similar way which
shape a devolution of biological
organism in humans then this natural
selection sometimes result in conflicts
when one of the type of artificial
intelligence shall be replaced by
another and they can kind of disagree
you should kind of leave the space and
kind of show which of them has more
resources more has more power control
more energy to defeat
a visitor there's a couple things here
oh this can be regulated by
international law and like the u.s. like
as good as the UN is working though the
markets market share and so on so I hope
that so today this natural selection is
done we are market share previously it
was a kind of violence now its market
share more so market share well in okay
so there's a couple things here one of
them is if there is no limitation to
resources then there is if you can have
access to whatever anybody has access to
then it's not as that though you have to
fight for anything at that point there's
there's tons of ways to structure a
society where you you having something
doesn't preclude me from having it so
that way we you and I can both have it
and if all seven and a half billion
people can have access to whatever they
want whenever they want it in ways that
are not greedy and power driven
egotistical so if we do things like
practice meditation spirituality if we
work on our collective spirit maybe we
can get to this point maybe maybe law
token proliferating blockchain and
decentralization maybe maybe that will
help quite a bit
decrease the amount of bureaucracy in
the amount of third parties and they'll
get us to that point faster I sure hope
it will and if--and I do I do tend to be
fairly optimistic about a future that
looks pretty bright with opportunity for
everybody and I hope that we can do that
yeah that's why I think you and I you
know vibe really well when you were
talking about your mission and purpose
that you wanted to provide the billion
people on the planet that didn't have as
much access to voting didn't have as
much access to currency to exchanging
things of value first
so we have cryptic change focusing on
liquidity new tokens new asset classes
that that I mentioned state things
elections and so on is this general
watching opportunity and I'm encouraged
mining to pronounce and politicians to
kind of tried them yeah but our focus is
capital markets because I have
background in capital markets I love
markets deliver incentives and there are
other great resources more efficiently
and create prosperous and move for
people to jobs their jobs and help
people to create more during their life
so that there are investors who are
allocated investors resources by
predicting future what will be more
helpful in the future and where we of
the great profits and where should be
valuation grow because of future profit
drops so this this is a kind of this
the very top point which you kind of
deliver incentives I love this yeah yep
it's a the way that you can deliver
incentives to people through capital
markets is very exciting and it fosters
innovation that fosters creativity which
are some of the most beautiful things in
the world when somebody comes up with an
invention or somebody comes up with the
business that provides utility to the
world yeah and by the way we have a
small video showing how our society
world business markets with the
bureaucracies and why they're sometimes
States collapsed because our
civilization is a set of rules
incentivizing us to organize chaos into
effective systems who defines these
rules is an age-old question
is it centralized power or free markets
and who enforces these rules bureaucracy
or something else
Homo sapiens drove 40 human species to
extinction when their leaders invented
religions to structure rules
[Music]
it seems this led to centralization of
power bigger tribes and increase
productivity competitors living in
Anarchy were defeated centralized state
seemed to be the only option until the
birth of democracy in ancient Greece in
Rome
when democracy was replaced by
authoritarian regimes empires tended to
decline
thanks to decentralized self-regulating
guilds Venice became a world trade
center but the power was monopolized and
Venice shifted from an economic
powerhouse to a museum
the decentralization of power in England
enhanced poverty rights
thus empowering innovators and
entrepreneurs to lead the Industrial
Revolution in the 20th century the crash
of the under-regulated stock market in
the u.s. resulted in the Great
Depression
crisis and social unrest led to the
centralization of power across
in some countries have led to extreme
violations of human rights
and others have led to the growth of
state regulation and state spending
however state monopolies resulted in the
deadly combination of unemployment high
inflation and corruption
Margaret Thatcher and Ronald Reagan used
Friedrich Hayek's free-market theories
to consolidate support from state to the
market eventually centralized planning
loss to free markets but the bureaucracy
still ruled the planet until the
invention of the blockchain Bitcoin has
already become a substitute for failing
financial systems and central banks in
countries suffering from hyperinflation
like Venezuela and Nigeria will
blockchain automate bureaucracy in every
aspect of our lives from capital markets
to government's will we have transparent
central banks and states on the
blockchain making crypto official and
creating regulation is one of the
primary subjects for discussion at the
blockchain economic forum can we save
one trillion working hours by automating
bureaucracy together with artificial
intelligence in the blockchain then we
develop an evolved system marking a new
era
[Music]
our traders focuses on new talk and so
the best place to list your talkin at
the first place is Latakia and we can
also list a pre-sale stage private sale
the white western KY see if you have a
security talking you can put it into you
a special part and provide kyc but this
is our goal to provide access for
qualified investors in a compliant way
to this type of tokens we gettin partner
was broken to a license to trade the
stock and some Asia so you're welcome to
apply for listing and why would I choose
lot oaken exchange versus some other
exchange we are focusing on liquidity
new tokens so if you have a new token
and if a great community and great ideas
how to spread adoption of this token
then we would list you and liquidity
will be the highest or for the beginning
of trade and we do it fast
we do not charge huge money we just
pretty small piece but we have purchased
elective in the same
couple questions on the way out what do
you think's the most beautiful thing in
the world the most beautiful the purpose
of life is to help each other to bring
more value this.value of the global
economy and their beauties that is
unlimited opportunity to do so so each
of us can bring trillions of value to
the planet and create innovations create
ideas which will be helpful for our
civilization and these ideas will be a
corporate and leave through generation
so each of us can we forever can live
forever if generate helpful innovation
so life is more like ideas or program
which is copied and replicated through
generation and this is a beautiful
opportunity what do you think we're
alone in the cosmos I think that there
should be interplanetary selection
that's why we shouldn't resist
technology girls of course there is a
risk that energy technology can be used
by one group against the entire
civilization if it's help to survive
this group and this technology can
contain some risk however there should
be some also interplanetary competition
so we should grow fast to be able to
talk
potential more developed it
civilizations but I don't have this
information yeah yeah many planets so we
know how life happened which and why not
it over somewhere else
yeah do you think there's a designer to
the universe
yes appear to all that God is an
unexplained force which create gravity a
weak and strong forces and I like a
magnetic film to these four forces
originated create seventeen quarks which
is a building blocks of everything as
our quantum physic things or something
like this so but there's still kind of
something unexpected and unexplained
inter yes when we can send it this is a
design it by somebody right something
which we can't explain we say okay this
is something behind this unknown
powerful and the design of this force
their result and design of everything
fountain thank you so much for coming
onto the show thank you this has been a
pleasure very great pleasures it to you
invited me here I like feel very
connected with all of you because kind
of you communicate these signals from
entire planets and if you like haha
we have lots of important fields of of
progress that we're trying to cover on
the show and one of the most important
ones is decentralization and so we're
having one of the leading
decentralization figures you on the show
and we're very grateful for that we were
grateful to come and do interviews at
the blockchain economic forum in San
Francisco a couple days ago we'll be
pushing out that content over the next
couple of days and what's next what's
next the San Francisco one just happened
where the next ones you said you were
doing Pakistan in the
I hope we will make and for cheap with
Wanda forums is we bring speakers with
very prepared messages people just have
very dense poor top ideas so they can
enough leapfrog their yes I do create
process of education so they come to the
frontier of known UI to kind of shift it
and we encourage you to join this trip
as to go to be a plateau can come with
your put information there mm-hmm
and we will bring some projects to
present this there I see us two very
huge communities in Vietnam this is I
believe sounds like next big market
after Korea cool
Pakistan is also weak and India so one
day conferences throughout these
different places for now week so go
check them out we'll have the links in
the bio definitely get more involved if
you guys had a good time learning about
decentralization go and tell to people
about what you learned they have them
tell to people let's go get the movement
started also definitely give us your
comment below don't just consume this
content go create with the make of video
make a blog post go write about it go
and teach other people about it start a
company in the space or go and hustle
everyone subscribe during the family
join us on patreon you continue
sustaining the studio continue expanding
our efforts to be able to go in and
interview continue interviewing really
smart people from around the world so
thank you so much everyone for tuning in
thanks around Vargas are producing
partner much love everyone we'll talk to
you soon thank you great
by tunity
[Music]